You might me wondering what the difference is
between statistics and machine learning. In short, the answer
is not much. More and more, the 2
fields are converging and they share many of the
same methods. However there are couple of significant
philosophical differences between the 2 subjects. Generally, statistics is
focused on analysing existing data, in drawing valid
conclusions, whereas machine learning is focused on making predictions.
What this translates to is the following: In statistics, we
care a lot about how our data was collected, and
drawing conclusions about that existing data using probability models. For
example, we might try to answer the question are left
handed hitters statistically better than right handed ones? In the
case of machine learning, we're a little bit more focused
on making accurate predictions and less committed to using a
probability model if there's a more accurate method that doesn't
use them at all. As long as our
machine learning method consistently makes accurate predictions for example,
how many home runs will a player hit, we
aren't too worried about what assumptions the model makes.